thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys where we have a
careful girl here today
so adila tell us about your podcast and
and your business in general we're all
curious okay
funny fun fact I had a podcast before
that actually had the word only fans in
it it got blocked from every ad ever
like you couldn't run any ads on it so
this new one I was like I gotta be
crafty and of offense like only fans is
[__] offensive and like at first it
was mainly to like try to destigmatize
the only fans platform which I still
think I do but in other ways like before
I would try to like learn about your
trauma learn your deepest darkest
Secrets but I'm in a phase right now and
I could go back to that but I just want
to hear about you like sucking dick and
like the craziest stuff you've done and
yeah like I it's like a good mix between
like serious and like fun and like uh
yeah recently I I like watch podcasts I
watch other people's podcasts and take
notes about what I like and then I'll
try to add that to mine to make it more
interesting and in my most recent
podcast episodes
um actually they haven't come out yet
but I just by the time this is out
they'll be out where um I have people
like turdley's and Kev play their Mormon
characters to interview people with me
so it's like there's characters in my
podcast now that are just like really
awkward
yeah yeah so um when did you start your
podcast so the first one I started
literally two weeks after I started my
only fans except we had to throw out the
episode because I thought I'd be able to
just watch a YouTube video on audio
engineer and then I [__] up the whole
audio and I didn't save the original so
it took like about a month after trying
over and over again before I'm like [__]
you just gotta pay someone when did you
start your only fans how long ago uh it
was
2021 October uh I think 30th 2021 it'll
lock down your life yeah well I I quit
my job I had a corporate job and it
sucked what are you doing uh Logistics I
did outside sales logistics in Arizona
walking door to door and [__] 100
degree weather
my anxiety and stress was so high that I
was throwing up every day I was uh
pooping blood and like I had like rashes
all over like stress rashes all over and
I'm like and then I took acid and I'm
like let me just start an only fans and
I quit and it's like you know not being
yelled at every day that's [__] sick
what inspired you to start so many sales
girls going into only fans yeah well
because this is like a less stressful
version of sales like there there's you
can use everything that you learned
about your job except now you're
actually selling something that you're
passionate about like yeah I want to
make dudes come before I was selling a
shitty Logistics service that was
probably more expensive than what you're
already paying for nobody was nutting
yeah no well actually some guys were
like if you come back in a bikini you
get the sale and I'm like wow and yeah
they were bold they were bold but um
she's like I respect that
that's like now I
know I've been and it's cool and like I
enjoy my job so I'm what was your
question because uh what inspired you to
like how come acid didn't go oh I'm a
train like a reindeer or like how did it
go straight like
how did it go because those two things
are Jason I had to go straight to only
fans I
yeah I already had followers like I was
very very well known in the Rave
Community specifically I wouldn't say I
was like famous in any other capacity
other than being known for raving so
like you know those ravers how are you
known in the Rave Community I got uh I
like I wasn't doing pasties and I got
repo reposted by like all of
it actually found that Instagram made me
delete it that one was that like
actually saved a bunch of photos and
stuff baby
and then this girl who I used to be
friends with put like printed out
pictures and uh set it on my dad's car
because she knew where I lived when we
were friends what a [__] [__] oh
she's a [__] [__] if you're watching
this you're a [__] was she hot though
um hahaha
that's even better attitude shift
so then my dad was like either I stopped
paying for college or you delete your
Instagram but then even after he made me
delete my whole Instagram that I had
been building like and honestly I was
depressed for like a few years after
that because it's like like people don't
think about social media it's like that
was me expressing myself to me it was
like a part of myself I put hours and
hours into building it like I even um I
made like a fake Instagram to like see
the theme like if all my photos
coincided it's like I was in it and then
um he made me delete it and then for the
next year to pay for college he followed
my Instagram and even if I was wearing a
Club dress he's like you look like a
[__] you need to delete this but a
dress I wasn't even in a bikini
um and then he told me I looked so cheap
these photos of these dresses and let us
judge
she has them
dad know what all these
all these yes he has the barometer for
what a horse he's like you look like
cinnamon over at Deja Vu
it's not gonna fly in my house this is a
[__] [__] from Temecula
you look like candy from Spearmint Rhino
I know that dress what a great question
dude it's okay you really don't have to
pull it oh man if I have you could so we
could be like yeah that's pretty hoary
yeah yeah that's a funniest thing to say
what are you doing out there looking
like a [__] temeculin this is what I
got paragraphs I can't see
I mean that kind of tells you already if
he
well
I'm trying to put myself in the position
of a dad
and it's like this was like
I wasn't even how old were you I was 21.
yeah that's too old for that too old for
that [__] yeah yeah I think also though
like there's a difference between a
father being
um
feeling a type of way and then using
that type of vernacular to express it
yeah why would you use those words to
your own daughter you know what I mean
I've said this before
I say it again I said on my own podcast
and people try to argue with me all day
every day but for a dad to say you look
like a hoe he is sexually sexually in
some kind of way and people are like no
he's putting himself in another guy's
shoe uh to see how they and I'm like so
he's putting himself in a guy's point of
view who is viewing your daughter
sexually so again you are sexualizing
her and it just it feels like dads who
don't sexualize their daughters are just
like oh like you look confident like you
know it's just like a much different
vibe so go up honey do you feel like
just honest question do you feel like
when you're wearing that though you're
wearing that in your life yo I feel sexy
in this I felt so hot in that because
it's like I I never knew how to style it
myself before the like I'm I was really
like pasties were easy you put a pasty
on with bottoms that match and that like
that's why I wore them I'm like that was
easy
um so I was like really excited or not
when I looked at pasties huh that's
stupid
you gotta get two happy faces two
flowers
two stars I would get the same
conversation where like my parents like
we're trying to be a gangster I'm like
yeah
thank you for noticing
that was for us it was like it's not you
don't get called a [__] they're just
like why are you wearing your pants so
[__] big yeah what do you want to be
a [__] drug dealer yes I do actually
I do that felt successful you're like
thank you would you say like since you
were already being sexualized you were
just like well [__] it if my fans are
gonna sexualize me anyway I might as
well get money out of it or like
actually it was really funny because for
a while and like if anyone recorded my
close friends story at the time God I
really hope they didn't but I'll just
admit it now I'd be like I don't want to
get paid for this I just do it because I
like it and then finally like it was the
acid I was like why wouldn't I get paid
for it it's because like you're taught
to feel shameful about wanting to get
paid for like feeling hot or feeling
sexy and it's like crazy because before
I started doing only fans you would have
never heard me say that I look hot today
or I look sexy today it was just like I
don't look ugly today but no once I
started and only fans I'm like I am kind
of hot like interesting I like I
masturbate to myself all the [__]
time wow but like I wasn't like that
before I'm gonna try I try because I
make videos like if I'm dating someone
make videos from and then I get soft
because I don't like watching me I don't
watch myself I feel like you're like
critiquing your own performance like
[__] I could have been fingering her
right here I just don't get turned on
seeing dick oh yeah so if I just see my
dick all day then I'm just grossed out
maybe maybe instead of instead of
looking at yourself in the video just
look at yourself in the mirror because
you know how you look different I have
to see if I'm in frame
[Laughter]
but then I would start and then I'd have
to stop the video after 10 seconds to
fluff again and watch a girl porno and
then I'm just like dude how does this
work yeah the science dude I don't know
how girls do it they could see
themselves and get turned on they can
all right yeah I'm bi but the weird
thing about me being by is I like girls
who look like me I like girls with fake
tits who are blonde so so Kaylee Gunner
yeah
see that yeah that makes a lot of sense
actually because then you're you can see
yourself being like turned on buyers
like yeah yeah who's your favorite
gently the one yeah this is a different
haircut today's video is brought to you
by hello fresh make meal times easy with
delicious recipes made with fresh
wholesome ingredients delivered right to
your door no lines no hassles just great
tasting meals that you can whip up and
enjoy I like to cook March's National
nutrition month oh really and hellofresh
makes it easy to choose dietitian
approved nutritious meals just look for
the dietitian windtag on the menu
choices so what I like about hellofresh
is sometimes you're tired of cooking the
same five meals that you know you know
what I mean you do it over and over
again you're like man I want to venture
out and try something new maybe another
country's Cuisine or something like
that's what I like about hellofreshes
everything incomes pre-packaged it's an
easy to follow recipe you bang it out
and that also teaches you how to use
some of the herbs that maybe you were
scared to use before
I'm afraid of coriander go to
hellofresh.com off the Record 60 and use
the code off the Record 60 to get 60 off
plus free shipping are you crazy go to
hellofresh.com off the Record 60 and use
off the Record 60 for 60 off plus free
shipping if you don't have money don't
complain just the way to get the food
man who's your fantasy Crush trying to
think I feel like full-on you want to
um collaborate with them yeah oh my God
they're like they're quite
they're quite like I'm obsessed with
Riley Reed I'm like obsessed with her
but like I also wouldn't want to collab
with her husband and I don't know if she
just does like girl girl like she does a
lot of threesomes and stuff
um I'd love to hook up with Tana Mojo
because I heard she's a giver
um hello I love her I love her she jokes
a lot about not showering but I would
still Bang
uh trying to think I don't really have a
lot of male celebrity crashes I feel
like the closest thing would be like
Pete Davidson or Tyler the Creator but I
still couldn't see myself actually
hooking up with them what do girls like
about Pete dinner they're
ugly hot
he's also like what do you call it like
um he is so thoughtful and like the way
he approaches dating women like he
actually sees him as people he's like
why wouldn't I go above and beyond for a
woman kind of thing like he's actually
like a really great guy to be in a
relationship with but
um I think he's talked openly I think he
has BPD or like he's on meds for like
something but he kind of takes on the
personality of the girl he's dating and
gets so wrapped up in them that he
forgets about like other people and but
he's a good guy how come he's like the
Reba he's like the rebound guy he's not
his main guy he's the guy that they
break up and then I need somebody to
make me feel beautiful because he'll
treat them the way that their main guy
didn't oh that's always a good thing so
he's the mistress
basically yeah but he's good he's the
fixer he's the fixer yeah yeah but I
still wouldn't date him just because
I've seen these patterns and like he'll
fall out over heels and then find
someone new and it's like I you know I
think there's some healing that needs to
be done the process but
fishing yeah
David there should be courses I like
Tyler the Creator he's [__] cool I
love love Tyler I like how on is amazing
yeah it's hilarious it's the first
celebrity crush but I also don't he he I
feel like he'd say mean things to me and
make me cry but it's like he's funny
oh genius yo did you see that interview
he had in Paris and then the the fashion
guy was like he was just trying to ask
him questions like uh so how do you like
uh Paris he goes I [__] hate it it
smells like [__] everyone's mean like I
hate Paris he goes what is the best
attraction when you're because you know
like he memorized these questions yeah
and so he has to do them right and the
whole time he goes I [__] told you I
hate France next question is like so
what do you love friends
no but Tyler's [__] funny he was my
first ever celeb crush and like tall and
skinny man and you probably could have
run into him multiple times being in
Hollywood too I could have always around
yeah but also like what I was obsessed
with him when I was under age you know
who was hitting me up when I was 16 was
riffraff whoa whoa weird but did he know
you were underage I don't think so you
just had an Instagram huh you just had
Instagram yeah but I mean I was
obviously at high school parties like he
could have used any deductive reasoning
to figure out that I I was in fact I
can't be assuming people use deductive
reasoning out here not in these streets
or he used deductive reasoning to figure
out you were underage
assumed that they use deductive reason
to figure out you're underage how many
letterman jackets are on the background
perfect
what college are you from a selfie in
homeroom huh
yeah desks desks that's the seductive
reason you'll be crazy it's all these
like big girls on Instagram are like I
have this guy in my DMs I have this guy
the biggest guy I've had in my DMs was
Sean Kingston and I'm like what is about
my Instagram that I don't care
we all know Sean okay that's a great
song but I guess it depends on which era
Sean Kingston yeah which era Sean
Kingston well it was this was last year
NFL
players NBA players I'm like do I need
to like sex up my Instagram more but
then if you sex it up then you get
deleted so so I'm like what do I need to
do I need more fillers let me know guys
I'll get more are these guys's
um techniques of flirting that's what
I'm curious about how do they approach
how do they DM should I pull it up he
just did he just go you make me suicidal
oh that's great I only have
half but okay this might not pull up
just because
um you no one knows the [__] Wi-Fi
yeah blame these two guys yeah welcome
to JK not what my own Wi-Fi was because
I haven't signed in in like the last
eight years that's the guy that doesn't
work for us anymore he's only want to
know that's true okay
you put this face
hit it in LA you we could record next
week but I'm done but I want to see you
today then I said as a platonic friend
he said LOL we'll have fun and then I
think I just blocked him because I was
like oh now he is suicidal the podcast
well no he like it was just weird
like we'll have fun like no do you think
maybe because you have a podcast that
some celebrities might feel like oh she
might talk to people about me hitting
her up I would you mean like this exact
moment right maybe that's why they're
like oh I don't know yeah I love the
part as a platonic friend that's a
platonic friend that's safe you know
what I mean yeah that is your Technique
right friend zone hard as [__] yeah
technique hey Sean you should have just
kept pushing for another three months
yeah dude yeah you're almost there dude
no he just I don't think I would have
like vibed with this music a lot like
like she's a dubstep Yeah
[Music]
what am I required like I have dated
enough guys who don't want to do dubstep
shows with me they need to want to go to
a DubStep show with me maybe they're
trying to save you from head banging
yeah oh yeah
yeah save her it sounds like you need a
high energy dude yeah the folk song
chill kind of guy won't go no too many
Jack Johnson's yeah I could
they [__] too slow yeah
yeah bpms RPMs well yeah BPM [__] me to
140 BPS
that makes me horny like there are
certain drops where I can feel my
panties get wet and I'm like I need a
guy to be there to do something
crazy frog Crazy Frog John Mayer don't
you meet guys at these shows that you
think might be it's crazy the hottest
girls like dubstep the ugliest guys like
dubstep and then the hottest great
combinations but I don't think as many
hot girls like house hot girls like
dubstep is there ways you guys can
combine and intermesh I would hope so
not just Skrillex yeah yeah he's like a
hot girl that does dubstep
half shaved head that's him I don't know
if he still has that you should bring it
back a decade no no he
yeah when was the first time you made
serious cash on only fans and said what
the [__] or did you strategy second
month second month I think my second or
third month the only fans I think I made
70k and then my third or fourth month
was like 107 and like oh my God it was
just and um were you just doing it
strictly off Instagram like um
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah I have quite a few but um it was
just crazy because it was actually my
podcast that took me off on only fans
only fans themselves reached out to me
and were like we love your podcast we'll
blow you up if you put it on our
platform and then that's how because my
first month I think oh I mean this is
still a lot of money I think I made like
11k in a week or something my first week
ever and then uh and then November I
only had it for a week before October
ended and that was 11k and then November
was like I don't know maybe like 13 14
which for me that was I was like oh what
the [__] I made 11k in a week and now I
only made like 13k in a month and then
all of a sudden in December I'm like how
did I just make seventy thousand dollars
Christmas yeah good [__] dude did you go
into this knowing the kind of numbers or
did you get surprised by it like what
the heck um
like smaller Instagram
I can make more of my Instagrams bigger
right and then I did I made a lot oh so
you kind of had an idea yeah I I was
like I quit my job my Logistics job
after 24 hours and only fans making one
I made a whole month salary I was like
yeah [__] you guys I'm out and then they
shout out logistics for you yeah they
gave me like one one month you made a
whole Year's worth of salary 24 hours 24
hours I made a whole month salary wow my
old job actually less than 24 hours so
then I walked over to my bosses it was
like a Sunday I walked over to my bosses
apartment I was like I'm out and it's
crazy because every single person at
that job unfollowed me I know they
called me a [__] I know the [__] that
they say but I'm like you could only
dream of making the money I have
um it's crazy here I mean like it just
sucks that they're so judgmental but I
also like they said a lot of stuff like
they would fat shame people they would
like talk about how ugly fat girls are
and like I'm like what about being a
kind person like girls don't find it hot
for you to like make fun of people but
so kind of lessons the blow that they
just said [__] about everyone they were
just jealous that people had confidence
unhappy generally yeah yeah but fat
girls typically are ugly
I'm just kidding you could like be my
face drop like
foreign